DREW BRADSTOCK: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining us
today for a session.
We're going to talk about
what's new as GKE turns 5.
I'm Drew Bradstock,
product leader for GKE.
And joining me today
is Alex Zakonov,
engineering director for GKE.
Now it's pretty amazing to
think that we're celebrating
GKE's fifth birthday today.
Now, I know we may
have promised cake,
but unfortunately,
that cake is a lie.
And what you're
going to put up with
is just this virtual version.
Alex and I had talked
about whether or not
it was a good idea to
sing happy birthday to GKE
in this session.
But thankfully, due to the
fact we're both awful singers,
we declined.
So with that, I'd like
to turn it over to Alex.
ALEX ZAKONOV: Welcome.
Today's an amazing day for us.
And we celebrated together
with all our customers,
customers who use GKE to
scale their applications
to meet huge demands of
[INAUDIBLE] Black Friday, Cyber
Monday, customers who use
GKE to run their banking
and financial
applications, customers
who use GKE to do
medical research
or learn how to optimize
self-driving cars.
That's an amazing day for us.
The journey towards that
day started way in the past.
It goes back to
2006, when Google
open-sourced the modern
concept of Linux containers.
That's how this started.
In 2012, Google was ready
to take the next step
and to start the work
on bringing in container
management at scale
and all experience
that Google internally
had with the technology
to the outside world.
And in 2015, Kubernetes
was unveiled,
setting the new
standard on what it
means to run cloud-native
infrastructure and cloud-native
applications.
A year later, in
August 2015, GKE
was born, making it
simple and available
for customers to run
Kubernetes clusters.
Customers loved the experience
with GKE and Kubernetes.
But they told us
that it's not enough.
They told that they gap from
legacy on-prem applications
to cloud-native applications
running in the modern cloud
is too big, that they need
help on their journey.
And we listened to them.
And in 2018, we
announced GKE on prem,
bringing in the power of
GKE to customer data centers
and allowing them to
modernize in place.
Customers told us repeatedly
that GKE is the gold standard.
And they need to
make sure that they
can leverage that gold standard
no matter where they are.
And this year, we announced GKE
on AWS, bringing in GKE power
to multi-cloud
customers who want
to have consistent, high-quality
Kubernetes experience
across on-prem and multi-cloud.
With that, we have
an amazing platform,
but it's only
started the journey.
There is way more to do.
And if we look on
the next five years,
we see a world where every
workload built around
on top of containers
and on top of Kubernetes
no matter if it's
[INAUDIBLE] or real-time,
a legacy workflow
or modern cloud-native
application.
And that's a high
demand that we need
to meet, making
sure that we have
reliable, secure,
scalable platform
to run any type of workloads.
So how are we going
to meet that demand?
So as Google continues
heavily invest in open source
Kubernetes, helping with scale,
security, and reliability
of Kubernetes, Google is
the number-one contributor
of investing all other
major cloud providers
as well as other
companies that support
Kubernetes distributions.
Google funds [INAUDIBLE]
for Kubernetes development.
Kubernetes is built and
distributed on GKE itself.
And all Kubernetes
testing is run on GKE.
This all said, Kubernetes is
still [? current. ?] Kubernetes
is extremely powerful platform.
That power comes
with responsibility.
And no offense to Kelsey,
but Kubernetes shouldn't
have to be the hard way.
And a huge thank you to
Kelsey and our DevRel team
for bringing all the
feedback on what we
need to simplify in Kubernetes.
And GKE is our answer to
simplifying Kubernetes.
With GKE, we take
complexity of Kubernetes,
and we are shifting
it from being
customer's responsibility to
being Google's responsibility.
With GKE, Google SRE team
is responsible for creating
GKE clusters in highly
reliable and scalable way.
Google's security team is
responsible for analyzing
and addressing all security
threats across the full stack,
starting from GKE Kubernetes
itself, going to Linux,
and going even to our
language itself, which is Go.
[INAUDIBLE] and Google
development team
is responsible for taking
all the knowledge that we
get from running millions of
workloads on top of containers
and converting it in a
set of new functionality
and innovation
for all customers.
One concrete example
of that innovation
is what we do is this
auto-scaling functionality.
Google constantly watches
internal and external workloads
running on top of
containers and builds
machine learning
predictable models
on how to scale workloads
in the most efficient way.
And we bring that
knowledge, that intelligence
to our customers.
GKE allows the automatically
scaled infrastructure,
supporting the result
of node auto-scaling,
as well as dynamically
scale your workloads,
supporting both the result
of port auto-scaling
as well as workload
auto-scaling,
making sure that your workloads
run efficiently and can
meet high-scale demands.
A concrete example of
that is our partnership
with Tokopedia, a major
Indonesian retailer that
needs to meet
high-scale requirements
of their peak retail season.
Tokopedia partnered with Google
to optimize their environment
to make sure that,
on one side, they can
run in a cost-effective way.
But on the other side,
when their customer traffic
increases, they can
dynamically meet those demands.
Another major
dimension is scale.
As new major workloads move
to containers in Kubernetes,
the demand for scale increases.
This year, GKE announced
15,000-node support
for Kubernetes clusters
riding on top of GKE.
And that was done
in a partnership
with our top customers,
such as Bayer Crop Science,
that uses GKE to run
genotype analysis,
analyzing 15 billion
genotypes per hour,
as well as Twitter,
who's using GKE to power
a real-time communication
platform across the world.
Please attend Twitter's
session to learn more about how
GKE is using--
how Twitter is using GKE to move
their [INAUDIBLE] and Aurora
workloads and megaclusters to
Kubernetes and GKE clusters.
Another interesting use
case is gaming, where GKE
is partnered with Phoenix Labs.
With gaming
applications, whenever
you launch a new title,
it's extremely hard, almost
impossible, to predict exact
scale that you will need.
As a result, in
many cases, you need
to design [INAUDIBLE]
for optimal scalability.
Phoenix Labs partnered
with Google and GKE team
around the launch
of their new title.
We designed the
infrastructure to make sure
that it will meet
their scaling needs
as well as partnered with them
on reviewing best practices
for their application layer.
As a result of that, whenever
[INAUDIBLE] title was large.
On the first week,
number of gamers
crossed 4 million gamers.
We are able to meet those
demands without [INAUDIBLE]..
Next, we are taking
all that co-innovation
with our top customers
and bringing it
to the next wave
of our customers.
And Drew will talk
more about that.
DREW BRADSTOCK: Thanks, Alex.
It's great to see that
level of partnership
with their customers.
Because that has been
the heart of GKE.
If we go way back to
the very beginning,
the first phase of
GKE and Kubernetes
was really around the builders.
These are companies put a
heavy [INAUDIBLE] investment
and their own time
into building new core
functionality into Kubernetes.
And we were able to
leverage that through GKE.
From there, we moved
to the next phase,
which is the cloud scalers.
That's where great firms
such as Shopify and Spotify
work with Google use
GKE to be able to obtain
that huge, massive,
global scale they
need to grow their businesses
to where they are in 2020.
From there, we've entered a very
different phase of Kubernetes.
This is where the
previous companies
were very cloud-native,
started in the cloud,
and grew in the cloud.
Instead, we're working with a
far larger number of customers.
We're actually moving from on
prem, are moving from VMware,
into containers.
And the needs of these
customers, what many of you
need, is very different from
the customers at the beginning.
Instead, they're looking
for a lot more simplicity.
Rather than having
50 different options
to do something and
full choice, they
want to have it a
lot more automated.
They want it more opinionated.
And they want more
help from Google
so they're not having
to build it themselves.
And this is where we get to
the next phase of Kubernetes
adoption and where
we're really taking GKE.
This is the wide-scale
adoption of Kubernetes
across enterprises, just
like Alex mentioned.
And what they're really
looking for is the ability
to take all the learnings Google
has across its massive fleet
of both internal systems as well
as GKE as a whole, globally,
and use that to be
able to automate much
of what they do to
run the system so they
don't have to worry about it.
Now a great example
of this change
is actually what we've seen
with the support of Windows.
Previously, and for a long
time, GKE was just Linux.
And this is great.
It allowed great scale.
But the challenge was much
of a business's workloads,
especially those that didn't
start in the cloud, were
trapped on Windows
servers and VMware,
which means that modernization
journey a lot easier.
By supporting Windows
as a first-class citizen
and having it fully in
GKE, it's really opened up
a lot of the migration
into the cloud [INAUDIBLE]
and also consolidation
onto Kubernetes clusters.
Hand in hand with
that though, it's
not just Kubernetes support.
It's help to be able to
migrate those VM-based apps
into containers, which
can be quite a struggle.
This is where
Migrate for Anthos,
which also works great
for Migrate with GKE such
that you don't need Anthos,
to help you, in an automated
fashion, move your applications
from VM containers,
be it in the cloud or
on prem, into GKE--
this takes a lot of the
risk, a lot of the time,
and a lot of the difficulty.
And instead, the tooling does
it for you, which can greatly
ramp up your journey into GKE.
Now from there, we need to
make the entire thing simple.
One of the things I get
often from customers is, hey,
we're on Kubernetes.
And it's almost an
implied question mark.
So what do you go from there?
Because that first
step of creating
a cluster can be
quite difficult.
And that's been a huge
amount of our investment
over the past year and a half
is to simplify that experience.
Take creating the cluster for
the first time in auto way--
automate away much of what
you'd normally be doing.
So rather than have it being 20
minutes and many, many steps,
instead, you can be live
in your first Kubernetes
cluster in only minutes.
And this really shifts
Kubernetes from the hard away.
And I personally learned from
Kelsey Hightower's great book
and went through
that lab experience.
So thank you, Kelsey.
But honestly, I don't want
many large enterprises
wanting to have to do that.
They instead want to be
able to do this smoothly
so they can go from
their first dev cluster,
to their first
production cluster,
to their second production
cluster, to their third,
and so on very smoothly, without
all this additional effort
for each one.
And that's where GKE
really stands out.
And you'll continue to see
more and more simplification
and GKE doing more
and more of Kubernetes
so you have to do less.
Now just like your initial
experience shouldn't be hard,
day 2 operations shouldn't
be scary, but unfortunately
are for many people.
This means, how do you
keep up with patching?
How do you handle upgrades,
be it for stateless
or stateful workloads?
How do you handle
security or issues
that pop up at the last minute?
This can often be a very
time-consuming initiative
that can slow down those
full production rollouts.
That's why,
specifically, we have
made a very strong
investment on this
in leveraging what we've
done with our SRE teams
and [INAUDIBLE] to look
across the entire fleet
to simplify things for you.
Great example of this
is release channels.
What this allows
us to do is pick
a GA version of Kubernetes--
so rapid, regular, and
stable are all GA--
and decide, based on
your risk profile,
or your particular
workload's risk profile,
which versions you'd want.
Now what I mean by
this is not everyone
wants to be
bleeding-edge, and not
everyone wants to be back
a couple of releases.
So if you've got a
workload that can never
afford to be going
down and you'd
like a much longer soak time
with this version of Kubernetes
out in the wild
for a long period,
stable is the best bet for you.
But if you want something
a little more current,
you can use regular.
If you want the latest and
greatest of Kubernetes--
and we certify the newest
version out and all its tasks
very quickly--
you can choose rapid.
Now the cool thing about
this is as GKE certifies
the next version in
rapid, regular, or stable,
we move it up for you and
automatically do the upgrades.
And this is huge.
Because it takes that risk,
takes all the security
patching, takes all the
testing out of your hands
and allows us to do it, and also
look across the entire fleet
so you benefit
from that as well.
And that makes day 2 a lot
simpler and a lot more stable
no matter who you are.
Really good example of
this is actually the work
that FACEIT did with us.
And FACEIT runs a
massive platform
for online multiplayer games.
And before they took
advantage of surge upgrades,
they were spending
about two weeks
upgrading their environments.
For any of you who have
lived through this,
you know how scary upgrades
can be, be it databases
or be it Kubernetes.
And being able to reduce
the risk and leverage
automated and
tested tools allowed
FACEIT to go from that two
weeks to less than a day.
The important thing
for this is less risk.
And also, it freed up their
team to work on other tasks
rather than focusing on
upgrades and building
all their own scripts, which,
over time, can be brittle.
And that's not where you
want your best engineers
in your platform
team to focus on.
Now if you look at
where we're going,
we're really just
getting started.
As we've spoken about,
a heavy focus for GKE
has been taking the
complexity of Kubernetes
and greatly simplifying it.
But that's not the
only thing we're doing.
If you look at scaling,
traditionally, people
talk about how far they can go.
And what's been key for
that, as Alex spoke about,
is actually the fact that
it was done in partnership
with customers like
Bayer and Twitter.
So we were running
real workloads,
and seeing what was
happening with them,
and testing all parts of
GKE so that we can scale
at small workloads, large
workloads, or any combination
of what you can throw at us.
Now the other side of this
coin is, how do we actually
optimize cost?
It's great if you can
scale up and handle
that maximum
capacity at any time.
But truly, you want to
be able to scale down
to meet the needs of
your business as well,
to free up compute and
network costs to be
able to really save you money.
And this is where the
team that's doing this
has focus on that scale-down
and optimizing for costs.
This can be with efficient VMs,
a new offering for GCP that
brings down your overall
compute cost, where
GKE can do that certification
and testing ahead so that you
don't have to, or working
in partnership with us
to take a workload that
completely changes globally
depending on time of day, which
we actually did with OpenX.
And just like the
session with Twitter,
there's a really
great one with OpenX
on what they did to handle a
global advertising application
and control costs
at the same time.
Now along with that,
there continues
to be a lot of
investment in security.
This is key.
This is something you want
some of the global fleet
to be taking responsibility
for and constantly
looking at harding your
application for you
rather than worrying about it.
So I think, as you
look at Kubernetes,
really, our innovation
is just getting started.
And I'd love to turn it
over to Alex Zakonov now.
ALEX ZAKONOV: Thank you, Drew.
Innovation is the
core of Google DNA.
And we had amazing five
years of innovation.
And we are looking
for the next five
years of bringing more
innovation to you,
the customer.
Please stay tuned for
additional announcements from us
in Q4 this year and
next year, letting
you simplify your operation,
to scale your workloads to run
efficiently, as
well as making sure
that all your enterprise
security needs on compliance
is met.
Thank you.